surprise Blake Lively is pregnant and
just debuted her baby bump at husband
Ryan Reynolds New York premiere of
Pokemon detective Pikachu the try to
talk to me all the time all they hear is
pika pika you can hear him right
although fans went nuts over Ryan at the
New York premiere of his new animated
film is the big premiere I haven't seen
a carpet this chaotic in a long time
it was Blake and her adorable bump that
turned heads on the carpet in this
gorgeous form-fitting and seemingly
Pikachu inspired yellow gown with a
thigh high slit the couple who tied the
knot in 2012 took the red carpet
opportunity to announce they're
expecting their third child together she
really does just show me how to be
better in almost every way as a father
as a person everything
Blake and Ryan are already parents two
daughters two-year-old Nez and four year
old James - James seemed to be when
you're all dressed up and looking so
incredible
Brian revealed to ET in April at the
Tokyo premiere of Detective Pikachu
she's the one that made this happen
pretty much did she get the checker
because she liked the voice she liked
how you sounded as Pikachu does she get
the chance she does
[Applause]
[Music]